Alright, so with the symmetric distributions like our normal
distribution, the one sided p-value is simply going to
be half of our two sided p-value. Remember that
the p-value is the probability that given the null
hypothesis is true, we would observe a test statistic
at least as extreme as what we saw. So
instead of having both sides of this distribution, we're
really only going to have one side of the distribution.
So we have a one-sided t-test where we're checking whether the
mean of sample one is greater than the mean of sample two.
We still want p over two to be less than our p
critical, maybe that's 0.05, but we want our t value to be
greater than zero. Whereas for a less than one-sided t-test, where
we're testing whether the mean of sample one is less than the
mean of sample two, we want p over 2 to be less
than p critical, but we want our t value to be less
than 0.